in this video we're going to come up
with some strategies for division when
the quotient isn't a whole number when
it's going to be a decimal so let's try
to compute 3/2 pause the video and see
if you can figure out what that is going
to be and I'll give you a hint it's not
going to be a whole number all right now
let's try to work this together and like
all things in mathematics there's
multiple strategies that you can use to
try to figure out what 3/2 is one
strategy is well let's just rewrite this
as a fraction so 3/2 you could write
that as you could write that as 3 over 3
over 2 now or you could say this is the
same thing as 3 halves but how can we
express this as a decimal
well you might recognize that 3 halves
is the same thing as 2 halves plus 1/2
let me write that down so this is the
same thing as 2 plus 1 over 2 and I'm
really doing every step here to
hopefully make things clear which is the
same thing as 2 over 2 so that's 2 over
2 plus 1 over 2 plus 1/2 I could break
this up into 2 over 2 plus 1/2 now 2
over 2 is just 1 and so this is going to
be equal to 1 and 1/2 now this might you
might meet let's say hey 1/2 I could
write that as 5/10 and that would be
exactly right you could just if you want
to spell out every step we could say
this is equal to 1 and since it when we
write it in decimal form we express
things as tenths or hundredths or
thousandths so 1/2 is the same thing as
5/10 and if we wanted to express that as
a decimal this would be equal to 1 and 5
tenths 1 and 5/10 now I did every step
here as you get more practice you say ok
this is the same thing as 3 halves
3 halves 2 goes into 3
one time and there's a half left over so
written writing this as a mixed number
it's one and a half and a half written
as a decimal is five tenths so this is
one and five tenths now another way that
we could have thought about this this is
okay I'm not getting a whole number when
I divide 3/2 maybe I'll get something in
terms of tenths so let me express each
of these in terms of tenths so three is
how many tenths well three is thirty ten
thirty tenths and we'd be dividing by
two we're going to be dividing so we're
going to be dividing it by two so thirty
tenths divided by two well that's going
to be equal to fifteen tenths this is
equal to fifteen tenths which is equal
to 10 10 10 5 tenths or 1 & 5 tenths so
both of these are equally legitimate
strategies for figuring out what 3/2 is
I like the first one a little bit it let
leverage is what we know about fractions
but let's do another example let's do a
few more examples this is fun okay let's
figure out what 34 divided by 4 is
divided by 4 and like before pause this
video and try to figure it out and try
to see if you can use some of the
strategies that we used in the last
video all right so as we just said we
could re express this as a fraction but
this is the same thing as 34 divided by
4 34 divided by 4 or 34 fourths now what
is this going to be equal to well 4 goes
into 34 8 times so it's going to go 8
times and you're going to have two left
over so this is 8 and 2 fourths 8 so let
me write it well now our eight and two
fourths you've got two in that blue
District fun 8 & 8 & 2 / 4 8 & 2 voice
so how do I do this again I said 4 goes
into 34 eight times and
I have two left over so I'm gonna have
two forts left over another way if you
want to see all the steps you could say
hey I could rewrite this as 32 over 4
plus 2 over 4 - 32 over 4 is our 8 so 8
and 2/4
well 2/4 that's the same thing as 1/2
that's the same thing as 1/2 and if we
want to express that in terms of tenths
this is equal to 8 and 1/2 is the same
thing as 5 tenths 8 & 5 tenths which if
we want to express it as a decimal is of
course 8 and 5 tenths or 8.5 and we are
done let's do another one of these and
actually let's do one of them where we
are dividing into a decimal where a
decimal itself is being divided so let's
say we wanted to calculate eight point
four divided by seven pause this video
and see if you can figure it out so when
you look at this you might have means
this too long okay I know 84 is
divisible by seven we know if you know
you're seven times tables we know that 7
times 12 is equal to 84 or that 84
divided by 7 is equal to 12
but this isn't 84 this is 8.4 so how do
we think about it
well one ways we can think about it in
terms of tenths eight point four is the
same thing as 84 tenths and so 84 tenths
divided by seven well 84 of anything
divided by seven is going to be 12 of
that thing so it's going to be 12 10 and
12 tenths we can rewrite as 1 & 2 tenths
or 1.2 1.2 and we are done
so this is equal to one point to another
way that we could have thought about
this is we could have said you know what
84 tenths is the same thing as 84 over
10 in fact you would read this as 84
tenths and now you want to divide this
by step
so you want to divide this by seven this
is the same thing when you divide by
something is the same as multiplying by
the reciprocal so it's 84 over 10 times
1/7 times 1/7 which is equal to we can
change let me write it this way this is
equal to 84 over 10 times 7 over 10
times 7 and now we could simplify this
if we divide the numerator in the
denominator by 7 84 divided by 7 is 12 7
divided by 7 is 1 12 divided by 10 this
is going to be equal to 12 tenths which
is 1.2 we could write this as 1 & 2
tenths or 1.2 let's do one more example
that's kind of related let's say we want
to figure out what 7 divided by 70 is
pause this video and try to figure it
out
well we can rewrite this as we've been
doing as 7 over 70 instead of writing it
as 70 let me write that as 7 times 10
and what's valuable about this is we can
divide the numerator and the denominator
by 7 we go if we divide the numerator by
7 we get a 1 we divide the denominator
by 7 we get a 1 remember we can do the
same thing to the numerator number if we
multiply or divide by the same value
we're not changing the value of the
actual fraction and so you're left with
1/10 which if you express it as a
decimal you go to the tenths place you
say I have one of those tenths that's
1/10 so this is 1/10 another way to
think about it is this is the same thing
as and really this is what we wrote over
here but you could write this as 7
divided by 7 divided by the blue 7 and
then you divide by 10 if you're dividing
by 7 times 10 we're dividing actually
let me write that out if you're dividing
by 7 times 10 and this essentially
another way of writing what we have over
here this is going to be equal to 7
divided by 7 divided by 10
/ 10 well 7 divided by 7 is 1 so you get
1 divided by 10 which is 1/10 1/10